je m'appelle Percy Jackson ma vie est
compliquée oui on peut dire ça mauvaise
note harcèlement tout ce qu'il y a de
plus normal mais il y a certaines choses
qui sortent un peu de l'ordinaire
tu as vu quelque chose
que personne d'autre ne voyait
ces histoires que je te racontais sur
les dieux grecs et les s’emmêler elles
sont bien réelles madame Jackson les
choses ont changé la situation évolue
beaucoup plus vite que ce qu'on avait
prévu cover tu peux m'expliquer
à l'important c'est de pas paniquer
merci Jackson
nous t'attendons
[Musique]
on a dérobé la foudre de Zeus
claquette et de la retrouver
[Musique]
souviens-toi de ce que je t'ai appris
il va falloir que tu sois courageux
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]